welcome to ap physics if you're looking
for phys ed that's in the gym and i
recommend you leave now
physics tells us that the universe is
governed by immutable laws kind of like
my classroom if you break my laws
you'll find out that for every
bone-headed action there is an equal and
opposite reaction
bronwyn
how good of you to help me demonstrate
this concept is this yours uh yes but my
phone's in my locker open it
this this isn't my phone
your action was to bring a cell phone
into class and my equal and opposite
reaction is to give you detention what
that's not fair because it's not my
phone it is fair and it's final you can
have your phone back after detention
okay people let's open our books now to
page 18.
how was it
hey
you ready to school me and debate so
ready
i just have to make a quick stop first
okay and attention
rojas detention on the first day of
school total misunderstanding can you
sell this fox i'll be late sure
uh i'm gonna stop by the cafeteria
lemon snuffle
you're the best
bronwyn i'm saturn i uh i didn't know
you were a fan i'm not that was a hate
read oh
that's a shame out of everyone i thought
you would get it get what
and i'm doing a public service
you don't think girls deserve to know
that reggie has a camera hidden above us
so it's a feminist app
you're like a teenage friend of para
so you do get it
now if you'll excuse me i have somewhere
to be
small world
me too
congratulations you're the only five
students in this entire school who could
still get detention every day this year
my experience the students who get
detention on the first day of school end
up here a lot so we might as well get to
know each other
i want you to write an essay introducing
yourselves and reflecting on what you
did to get here there'll be no talking
no passing notes and no more doodling
miss avery i know you didn't believe me
in class but that phone you found wasn't
mine so i
technically don't belong here
well no browner would never
intentionally break the rules no i
wouldn't and i didn't
see my phone's right here did you
seriously bring another phone into
detention hand it over sorry but does it
the fact that you're confiscating my
phone twice seem weird to you i mean why
would anyone have two phones well i can
think of a few reasons
what about you nathan
what's your problem man with you well i
think you know enough
papers and pens out
if i'm gonna stay here unfairly could i
at least use my computer i try to avoid
paper for environmental reasons oh well
i try to avoid devices that connect to
the internet for making sure that you
actually do your work reasons but oh
another word and you'll have detention
again tomorrow and i don't think either
of us really wants that do you
how are there more questions simon this
is a very simple assignment i just need
to go get my water from my locker no you
can go 45 minutes without water well
actually no i can i have xerostomia it's
a medical condition where my salivary
gland's underperformed yeah i know what
dry mouth is you may get a cup of water
from the water cooler the cups and no i
don't care that the cups are made out of
paper bronwyn
what i do care about is that everybody
is quiet and doing their work it's a
thousand words so i recommend that you
start now
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
yeah i want to see real progress on
those essays by the time i get back
[Music]
oh my god that's the laguna guys right
that's insane [ __ ] laguna
addy do you uh
recognize any of those asses
what's that supposed to mean that just
means that you have sex with jocks so i
thought you might have seen them naked
your obsession with other people's sex
lives is seriously pathetic
what about you coop
what about me simon
just from the locker room
i'll spend my time with the locker room
staring at other guys asses
[Music]
oh and of course they got away you know
nobody at this school would get called
out for anything if it weren't for me
why do you care what happens to them
well it's not about them
it's about the principle of the thing
the principal but there's so many
privileged [ __ ] in the school who
just think they can get away with
anything because what
rules don't apply to them
it's [ __ ]
this tastes weird
i think there's something wrong with
this
simon are you okay
i'm calling 911
[Music]
you